Beccatevi
[Musica]
questa mercoledì
[Applauso]
[Musica]
mercoledì non mi sono mai divertita così
tanto nemmeno un
funerale sull'albero
oggi nuova Challenge
Barbie contro mercoledì uh
sì Ciao Noi siamo il team delle
mercoledì e io sono mercoledì Alice e
lui è Io sono mercoledì Vitale e sono il
sorello di mercoledì e lei è io sono
mercoledì psicopatica e sono la sorella
di mercoledì E noi siamo il team delle
Barbie Io sono Barbie Anita e lei lui
lei è Barbie francona la Barbie rossa
e lei Io sono Barbie grangala un
aristocratica ci sfideremo in una serie
di Challenge per vedere se vincono le
Barbie o le mercoledì e se voi fate
parte del team Barbie cliccate un mi
piace se invece fate parte del team del
mercoledì lasciate un commento qua sotto
ed è appena uscito il mio nuovo libro La
città stregata è ora disponibile on in
libreria prendetelo subito e
comunicheremo assieme dei messaggi
segreti con l'alfabeto segreto del libro
Questo è un messaggio per voi traduc
metelo e Inviatemi un messaggio su
Instagram con la traduzione e Vi
saluterò ma ora pronti iniziamo subito
con la prima Challenge
sì la prima Challenge sarà una Challenge
di sopravvivenza fuori all'aperto
Vediamo chi riesce più a sopravvivere
fuori nella natura noi Barbie o le
mercoledì Ah noi Barbie ci siamo
organizzate benissimo per questa
esperienza nella natura infatti abbiamo
organizzato un picnic con tantissimo
cibo e anche una copertina per sederci
Come delle vere Barbie aristocratiche Sì
esatto cara Ho portato anche delle altre
merendine Perfetto grazie Barbie
figurati Barbie Secondo me le mercoledì
non ce la faranno a sopravvivere nella
natura sicuramente moriranno di fame Io
odio la natura Io odio la luce del sole
Io odio stare più di 15 minuti senza
mangiare Ah tranquillo Vitale troveremo
una soluzione Non possiamo perdere la
Challenge Eh no ma tu hai portato da
mangiare no E tu no Io ho già
mangiato però Sento odore di cibo
sentite anche
voi
Guarda le Barbie hanno portato da
mangiare Oh sì è tanto andiamo a
rubarglielo
Sì
Ah si sta benissimo vinceremo
sicuramente noi la Challenge Ciao Barbie
che buon profumo che c'è qua quanta
roba un po' con noi no perché dobbiamo
vincere noi la Challenge questa è roba
nostra ma io sono affamato qui non mi
interessa
Sloggi E se io faccio così ma
come bravissime siamo riusciti a
scacciarlo il mercoledì Mi sa proprio
che abbiamo vinto noi questa
Challenge stato troppo difficile siamo
stati schiacciati Già ma io ho un'idea
Oh spaventiamo le facciamole scappare Oh
sì forza andiamo
Sì allora Barbie Perché non parliamo
male di Ken adesso Sì assolutamente Come
va col tuo Ken Barbie abbastanza bene e
a
te io non ho un Ken ancora non l'hai
trovato perch non posso avere un Ken Il
mio invece è acculturato è un principe
Wow Fortunata Ah che meraviglia sembra
di stare a Barbie
[Musica]
Land Eccomi eccomi ce l'ho fatta questa
volta il nostro pieno Ha funzionato
adesso si spaventerà e vinceremo noi la
sfida finalmente mangeremo e finalmente
Ado dentro non ce la faccio più con
questo
sole Che schifo sono state mercoledì
sicuramente Beccatevi
[Musica]
questa pensavano di spaventarci e
rubarci il cibo ma non ci sono riuscite
e quindi la prima Challenge l'abbiamo
vinta noi Barbie forza Team Barbie e ora
seconda Challenge la seconda Challenge
sarà una gara di velocità vediamo se
sono più veloci le mercoledì o le Barbie
via
tanto vinceremo noi mercoledì voi Barbie
siete troppo delicate per correre al
massimo potete farlo in una passerella
meglio in una passerella che in mezzo ai
cimiteri
[Musica]
sgorbi ce la puoi
fare dannati tchi non ci riesco Oh no i
tacchi di Barbie sono troppo scomodi sta
andando lentissima non riuscirà mai a
raggiungere
mercoledì
Ho vinto io Barbie sta ancora lì non mi
sono mai divertita così tanto nemmeno un
funerale non sono mai stata umiliata
tanto Hi
Barbie Uffa Barbie grangala ha perso ma
ora proverò io a vincere perché io non
ho i tacchi oggi Neanch'io ho i tacchi
oggi
Barbie Barbie Barbie Barbie mercoledì
mercoledì mercoledì
mercoledì Barbie Barbie
barb Eh guarda guarda c'è una pizza Oh
la pizza Dov'è la pizza Oh la pizza
Oh siè cascato ce l'ho fatta Ho vinto io
questo round Dov'è la pizza non l'ho
trovata non c'è nessuna pizza ho io Ma
come non c'è la
pizza e mi ha ingannato passiamo ora al
terzo round io sono carichissima perciò
corrò un sacco veloce sono sicura che
vincerò io e invece vincerò io copiata
Rocca di uno zombie Ehi Barbie Rossa
Togliti i tacchi altrimenti perderai
come Barbie galà toglitti presto toglili
toglili no E qu R col petto non li
togliere Non è vero Ahia hai ragione
Grazie Mar stereotipo
[Musica]
Ah si è tolto i
tacchi Barbie cosa sta
succedendo Sì abbiamo vinto lo sapevo No
no abbiamo
perso Sì abbiamo vinto noi Festeggiamo
sì ah
Ah che gioia abbiamo vinto davvero
bellissimo Uffa noi Barbie abbiamo perso
questa Challenge ma manca ancora la
terza Challenge che sarà la Challenge
decisiva siete pronte certo quella la
vinciamo di sicuro
esatto per la terza Challenge avremo una
gara di un veicolo telecomandato e noi
ovviamente abbiamo scelto C Rosa di
Barbie Wow È bellissima ed è Rosa ma
bella e speriamo che sia anche
velocissima per battere le mercoledì
Vediamo loro cosa hanno scelto Noi
mercoledì abbiamo scelto qualcosa che ci
rappresenta Sì uno scarafaggio è piccolo
ma sicuramente riuscirà a battere le
Barbie è velocissimo e si
spaventerà
[Musica]
eh aspettate perché non
ci schiaccialo
schiaccialo Ma che cosa stanno facendo
Ci vogliono schiacciare dai corri
piccolo Gino piccolo Gino
[Musica]
corri non è colpa mia è colpa della
macchina a
sinistro
non sno neanche guidare una macchina
telecomandata vinceremo Noi sì Scar alla
grande u non riesco a prenderla gira a
sinistra ma sto girando intorno Aia Mi
sta venendo il
[Musica]
capo Senti vieni guid Dai dai da tieni
la Doretta non possiamo farti battere
dallo scarabaggio Ma come funziona
questa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cosa Oh no c' hanno schiacciato come
facciamo adesso sì
prov oh no non mi dire che abbiamo rotto
la macchina schiacciando lo scarafaccio
nelle mercoledì no no no le cose si
stanno facendo male Sì sì vai
Gino dai
schia bravissima Mar CH di
nuovo
Bravo oh no qualcosa è andato storto lo
scaraggio non sta andando avanti si sarà
rotto qual cosa non sta
[Applauso]
funzionando Oh no Come abbiamo fatto a
perdere contro le Barbie abbiamo solo
avuto sfortuna ma in certi casi la
sfortuna ci
piace in questo caso no Sì abbiamo vinto
noi
Barbie e abbiamo vinto il di nuovo libro
la CIT stregata e se voi ancora non ce
l'avete correte subito a prenderlo
perché è ora disponibile e Ora andiamo a
leggercentroestetico
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ci sarà
Femmine contro
[Applauso]
maemo noi vemo
noi Io sono Anita e faccio parte del
team delle Femmine vinceremo noi il
libro La città stregata che ora è
custodito in questa teca perché è molto
prezioso non faremo vincere i maschi Io
sono Alice e sono del team delle femmine
e la vittoria è nostra Io sono Ginny
come sapete del team delle femmine e
grazie a questo martello e alla mia
super capacità di trovare tutti
vinceremo noi Ciao a tutti io sono
Vitale e sto andando a mangiare sto
andando a nascondermi per prendere il
libro di Edita Stories ovviamente e
vinceremo noi vinceremo noi del team dei
maschi andiamo Ciao ragazzi io sono
Frank del team dei maschi e ora corro a
nascondermi perché molto modestamente lo
voglio vincere Io quel libro non voglio
essere battuto dalle femmine sarebbe
troppo un'umiliazione Io sono Manuele e
faccio parte del team dei maschi qui non
lo sa nessuno ma io sono un campione di
nascondino e oggi ve lo dimostrerò per
il primo round si nasconderà la squadra
numero due cioè i maschi dovranno
mimetizzarsi quindi si divideranno siete
pronti iniziamo subito a contare
via
1 2 3 Oh ragazzi Ragazzi dove andiamo a
nasconderci
[Musica]
no Eccomi non c'è posto migliore dove
nascondersi della cucina e in più in
cucina potrò anche mangiare Che bello
non vedo l'ora Possiamo
[Musica]
nasconderci non mi troverà mai qui Anzi
mi è venuta
un'idea Sono nascosto
benissimo Il tempo scorre dove mi
nascondo qua no mi vedo troppo Ho
un'idea qua non mi troveranno mai Sono
nascosto dentro la siepe con questa
tutina verde nessuno potrà trovarmi
perché mi nasconderò nell'erba e quindi
mi
mimetizzato che sono il campione di
nascondino
[Musica]
andiamo
30 siamo pronti a trovare tutti i maschi
da che parte Andiamo Secondo voi di là
oppure di là Ho un'idea Dividiamoci così
avremo più possibilità di trovarli hai
ragione Sì andiamo Eccomi sono nel posto
preferito di vita
la cucina sono sicura che lo troverò
qua oh no sanita che sta
arrivando
Ehi Vitale dove
[Musica]
sei ti ho
trovato non è nascosto qua Eppure mi era
[Musica]
sembrato
Vitale Ma
[Musica]
dov'è
Vitale ma cosa stai facendo dividendo il
panino con Merlino e praticamente mi ero
nascosto qui però Merlino voleva
mangiare allora abbiamo deciso di
dividerci un panino Beh mi dispiace Ti
ho trovato quindi hai perso e ora vado
ad aiutare le ragazze a trovare gli
altri due maschi Oh no mi ha trovato
basta Merlino non mi mangiare tutto il
panino Secondo me qualcuno si è nascosto
in quelle siepi e ho un modo per
trovarlo geniale Invece secondo il mio
intuito qualcuno si trova qui in zona
andiamo a trovarli Sì forza Team femmine
vai dove si saranno nascosti vediamo se
sono qua magari potrebbe essere
sull'albero
[Musica]
bene ora Vi insegnerò un giochino e si
chiama trova la
talpa 1 2
3 Oh no sto martellando la siepe
Speriamo non mi
trovi e adesso il colpo
finale
3 Eccoli Li abbiamo trovati Ah che
stupido non
respiro sei
stupido FR Ma com'è possibile
battezzato
avevo
[Musica]
visto per il nostro round abbiamo
preparato una trappola per i maschi è
perfetto sì eh sì sì sì e non mangiarle
Mi raccomando sono per i maschi questi è
una trappola per distrarli abbiamo
riempito il piatto di
dolcetti e questo lo lasciamo
qua SH e ora andiamo a nasconderci forza
andiamo adesso tocca a noi dobbiamo
riscattarci Hai capito sì e ce la faremo
alla grande iniziamo a contare Camo noi
questo round iniziamo a contare dai sì
andate a nascondervi voi 1 2 3 4 io mi
nascondo qua dietro a questo albero
gigante Ehi Ma voi avete cliccato mi
piace cliccate mi piace se F fate parte
del team delle Femmine Se invece fate
parte del team dei maschi lasciate un
commento qua
sotto con questo mio travestimento da
manichino non riusciranno mai a
trovarmi Speriamo di non muovermi
troppo devo trovare un posto per
nascondermi dobbiamo
vincere va bene
dai sono sicura che non mi troveranno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mai allora piano piano piano ma che
piano piano trovarle tu vai di là Io
vado di là tu Bravo Ok andiamo via dove
devo andare io non mi ricordo più forse
di qua il mio istinto mi dice che
qualcuno è uscito di casa Oh no si sta
avvicinando e quindi Essendo io il
campione di nascondino devo per forza
trovarne almeno una Allora vediamo dove
può essere sotto il vaso no dietro la
siepe No una ragazza non si
nasconderebbe mai dietro la siepe forse
dietro qualche albero vediamo un
po' si sta avvicinando sempre di più mi
sa che mi ha
scoperta Mamma mia ma do diavolo possono
essersi cacciate
queste qu No qua
[Musica]
no chissà dove si saranno
cacciate bella questa
libreria molto bella anche questa Ma
questo manichino è super realistico
adesso lo abbellisco
io allora questo manichino riuscirà a
tenere
questa e riuscirà anche a tenere
queste
interessante vediamo un
[Musica]
po' dove si saranno cacciate noi del
team dei maschi dobbiamo vincere il
libro di
[Musica]
Anita
Non ci posso credere è così semplice è
proprio qui sicuramente sotto questo
pupazzo ci sarà nascosto qualcuno
controlliamo Ma non ci posso credere Non
c'è nessuno
[Musica]
qui lì o lì o lì forse lì andiamo a
vedere Mi è venuta un'idea ma anche
secondo voi questo manichino sembra
Alice Uffa mi hai trovata E che cavolo
pensavo di essere un manichino
Perfetto cosa è successo ma almeno mi
sta
[Musica]
bene L'ho trovata L'ho
trovata ma questo è Frank Forse le ha
trovate tutte lui andiamo a controllare
eh eh l'avete sentito questo sembrava la
voce di Frank forse ha trovato tutte le
altre abbiamo vinto Sì
V siè mancato poco Ciao sono l'emoji di
Anita sono qua per ricordarvi che appena
uscito il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo subito mi sono salvata Ma
perché è corso
dentro andare controllare
e
meraviglia Frank Frank Che cosa è
successo le hai trovate Sì le hai
trovate Ehi che succede Ragazzi ho
trovato le dolci Grande Frank bravissimo
Che cosa c'hai in testa effettivamente
eri un po' strano
ragazzi per
noi
Grande
[Musica]
Ehi avete smesso di cercarci
Quindi abbiamo vinto
noi siete caduti nella nostra trappola
quindi ha vinto il team femmine possiamo
finalmente prendere il libro La città
stregata è nostro e se lo volete anche
voi correte in libreria o prendetelo in
libreria on È ora di disponibile la
città stregata gli investigatori del
mistero
no Lo volevamo noi libro perché siamo
così stupidi perché ci hanno ingannato
col cibo è normale Esatto Non vale
questo è un colpo basso non va bene
Vabbè Guardate il lato positivo almeno
ci abbiamo riempito la pancia è vero
ancora dobiamo mangiare
[Musica]
via
e